listen um I thought is something so
nasty yesterday my dog sniffs buttholes
for fun and even she was like oh
[ __ ] Oh what is going on YouTube
now in the recent years there has been a
very interesting movement that's right I
said of both but yeah the shoe game has
gotten out of hand now don't get me
wrong I have always been into kicks
since I was a kid when I was younger I
was too broke to buy JSTOR when I got my
first paycheck you best believe huh got
me some Dave one five six it's
I know what you're thinking [ __ ] I
don't care I'll handle it dreams but
here to think the obsession with issues
have gotten out of hand because these
things are hard to buy and they
expensive as fine so you already know
what it is LCR baby let's get it let's
go oh [ __ ] y'all my shoes if you don't
wear that oh my god how you gonna buy
shoes but never put them on your feet
that make any goddamn sense to you let
me ask you something
you ever see a goat [ __ ] unicorn no
that's right because that shit's [ __ ]
stupid
listen I understand that you want to
collect a few but did you understand
where I'm coming from with this huh if
you have to rearrange your room to
figure out where to put your shoes you
might have a problem if you cannot feed
your kids but still buy yourself a pair
of days just visualize the sandwich
you'll be fine
you might have a problem and someone
asked you to suck dick for a pair of j's
and you did this suck some dick some
james the [ __ ] commission hmm you might
have a [ __ ] problem if your heavy
shoe proms up your pet for you son check
out 99 problems and yet still buy your
shoes got me doing this [ __ ] thing you
know the whole thing when you're on to
get mad at you is [ __ ] what hazel has 72
pairs of shoes but you still don't know
how to dress yourself [ __ ] shoes
can only do you so much
you ever see those dudes with like $400
kicks but couldn't match an outfit to
save his life I go outside looking like
a big mistake let me put it to you like
this
shoes on your feet is like rims on a
[ __ ] Pinto and yeah you the Pinto has
gotten to the point where if you wear
cakes people actually come up to you and
wonder why you wearing them on your feet
no [ __ ] I wore a pair of j's yesterday
and this dude came up to me and said oh
oh you got the haints on your feet oh my
what the [ __ ] out but I'll do a shoe
stupid and he had the audacity to say oh
my you ain't got the H on your feet you
know playing basketball you you playing
basketball play ah oh you not play you
didn't quit no babe basketball shoes
[ __ ] oh my god what people gotta
get raffle tickets to buy sneakers
nowadays
[ __ ] ain't chuck-e-cheese [ __ ] you
see kicks that you want to cut really
bad you got to go through this whole
raffling system why is that what you
want mr. Michael Jordan huh you want a
bunch of babies outside of Compton
holding the ticket to buy some damn
shows how do you sleep probably the [ __ ]
to the money huh yeah I would never
smack the child but there's a kid out
there there's wearing shoes that I want
and you ain't gonna put them on your
feet I might have to kill you
because these [ __ ] are hard to
buy and they find a Heineken tentatively
okay if you have to read if you have to
rearrange your rooms if your room if you
have the real radio room